Tony Dungy set to join us Hall of Fame
coach football night america analyst and
good to have you on Tony how are you
this morning
hey DP I'm doing well how are you guys
there we're doing great we're still
trying to figure out this Andrew Luck
situation because I think everybody was
surprised but I'm curious when do you
think the owner and the coaching staff
knew that Andrew Luck was going to do
this Dan I was at practice a week ago
Thursday they were scrimmage in the
Browns I was out there Andrew wasn't
working full team with the team he was
working like a maniac
he's on boxes and doing these agility
drills and doing his pass sets and
throwing balls a thousand miles an hour
I talk to him for five minutes and you
could see the frustration that he wasn't
out there but I left my five minutes
thinking you know maybe not week one but
week two week three will definitely be
there
Payton was there the same day painting
talked to him for about 30 minutes and
they're talking about you know
recovering from injuries and all the
things Payton went through and he came
away with the same thing that this guy
is so close to being there so I don't
think any of us saw that now not Frank
Reich told me that that Andrew was going
through some frustrations with an injury
why is this ankle not healing but I
don't think anybody really saw this
coming until maybe this past week we
don't even know about the injury Tony I
don't know the severity is there surgery
why wasn't it responding I mean there I
think that's the frustration in his mind
what is going on with this I've done all
this work it should be better it should
be perfect it is and what is really
going on and I think that was really
part of it is that I'm not sure what's
happening with my body right now let me
put you in Frank Reich's position here
and Andrew Luck comes in and he says
that he wants to retire you know you
have this player that you know you're
invested in in a variety of ways and you
have a job here and you're trying to you
got a Super Bowl quality team but what
would you say to Andrew Luck if he came
in and said what he said do Frank Reich
well what I would say is hey let's make
sure that this isn't a quick emotional
reaction I understand your frustration
Andrews you've got these injuries
nothing in my ever going to be a hundred
percent maybe I'll be playing this
season maybe I'll be playing the rest of
my career it at 90% or 85% but you know
what that's still good enough to get us
to the Super Bowl now I want you to do
that if you don't think you can and you
don't want to play at that level or
there is this pain management that
you're dealing with I understand that
we're going to support you but give me
give me four or five days to think about
this and you know let's see where it
goes and maybe that's what happened
maybe that's what they did
because when I saw him I'm telling you
he was working out like a crazy minute
it just it it it feels reactionary but
then there's also part of this that
knowing Andrew Luck I'm guessing that he
spent a lot of time before making this
decision I don't think it was right now
yes yeah this is something and maybe it
started with the shoulder injury you
know a couple years ago where he missed
the whole season I don't know but yeah
this was not just a I woke up yesterday
and I decided I'm gonna retire no no way
Tony Dungy football night in America
analyst hall-of-famer joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner how
different will the Colts offense be with
you Kobe Bruce said in there instead of
Andrew Luck they'll be different but it
could be just fine and that to me is the
beauty of Frank Reich in the coach and
this is it really if it was going to
happen this was the best way for it to
happen Andrew took none of the work in
the spring none of the words in the
summer none of the worked in training
camps was jacolby percent has been in
there they have been working on Jacobi's
offense the whole time and it's
different and Frank understands it when
he went into games in Buffalo it was
different than when Jim Kelly was in
there so he's going to be able to put
that together and he's going to be able
to transmit that same confidence and I
can tell you this now that team has
confidence in Jacoby they feel like
they're going to be good Frank feels
like he's going to be good Frank feels
like hey I could have won
four Super Bowls I'm not Jim Kelly but I
could have been there and you know
directed the team they didn't made me so
we didn't have to do it
but if I had to do it I would have been
able to do it and he feels the same way
about Jacobi this is a bigger deal
because it's a quarterback a quarterback
in his prime and number one pick overall
a guy who has made money was going to
make a whole lot more money as opposed
to you know Gronk retires and nobody's
going yeah we might go all he might come
back but you know they it feels like
people got angry at Andrew Luck can you
expect yeah they did and the suddenness
of it I think and unexpected I
remembered and I think I told you about
this I'm coaching the Tampa and talking
to Barry Sanders before it came out
she's just haunting me my whole I was in
Minnesota not me I can't get away from
you you get 200 yards every time we play
you you know and he told me he said one
of these days you're gonna look up and
I'm not either
and he gained eighteen and nineteen
hundred yards and then just stepped away
and it was crazy but you know he is
something he's been contemplating and
the money didn't mean anything to him he
was close to Jim Brown's record that
didn't mean anything it was just time to
go that's the joy at the game had left
and he was gone and it reminds me the
same thing it's a little more sudden
with Andrea the fact that he went to
training camp knew before I think that's
what got people thrown off had he said
this a day before coming to camp maybe
more people would have understood it and
taken it a little better I'm curious
your thoughts on the Rams and the reason
why I bring them up losing is Super Bowl
and then trying to come back the next
year we've seen those teams and there's
a long list of teams that didn't even
make the playoffs the following year
what is it about the team that loses the
Super Bowl trying to get back there the
next year it is so devastating to lose a
playoff game period there's a lot of
focus on that and you second-guess why
but the Super Bowl there is so much
focus and so much second-guessing and so
much emotion an energy you put into it
and and you go longer than everyone else
so now as a coach you kind of balance
how do we get back and get get back at
the grind but still pounce I got to give
these guys
some arrests and and then all now the
social media and everything is just so
difficult but Buffalo get to go four
times in a row and lose that is so
incredible people can't even imagine
that but it's gonna be difficult on the
Rams and then you've got the Todd Gurley
situation is he going to be the Gurley
that we've seen before
under the 80% of head who takes that
role and how much are they able to run
there's just a lot of things that go
into it this first month the season will
be very very interesting for the ramp
yeah and you start to look at some of
these teams like the Cowboys right now
you don't have a Zico Elliot I still
expect him to be there week one but but
when you don't have that player as a
coach like you know Jason Garrett trying
to get this team ready for you know this
season how how difficult is that right
now when you don't have the player that
you built your entire offense around
it's tricky and the tricky part is do
you assume you're going to have them or
not you know you can say hey we're going
to have Zeke and so we're going to do
everything the same way and we're going
to get ready knowing that he's going to
be there well if that's your approach
and then he's not there you're really
stuck
do you practice and prepare we've got to
do a little different because we're not
going to have Elliot and and so this is
going to be our focus now and then you
have to readjust when he comes back
that's why this is actually pretty good
for the Colts they haven't had to
structure that and say you know what
Andrew we think he's going to be back so
we've got this offense in place but
until then we're going to do this with
Jacoby now they know exactly what
they're doing
the Rams I'm not sure do they know how
much time is going to be able to give
them in the running game and how much to
build around him I'm like you I'm
assuming Jason Garrett and the Cowboys
say you know what someway somehow we're
like this money things straight now
we're going to have week one that's the
way we're preparing I've been saying
this and I may you know turn out to look
like a fool but I think there'll be a
market correction on Patrick mahomes
with Kansas City you know defense is
find a way to go okay now we're gonna
adjust to you but I even if he throws
like 40 touchdowns might be a
disappointment
people but so what do you see defenses
doing with mahomes this year that maybe
they didn't do last year well one thing
that I think people are overlooking
Kareem hunt was such a factor in that
offense and I mean he was a great runner
the screen game all of that so now I
think you're going in and saying you
know what we've got to do whatever it
takes to stop Patric mahomes but maybe
display eight defensive back and make
them run the whole time there's gonna be
a focus on this passing game and who's
going to step up in the run game if
people I could see Bill Belichick doing
this we're going to play eight defensive
backs and three linemen and just hope
you run every play and will you do it
and will you run and I think that's what
Patrick's gonna have to deal with but he
I think this kids a special thing I
really do I don't think he's gonna drop
off that much Tony good to talk to you
tell the boys I said hello have fun on
football night in America and always
appreciate your time well dude we got to
get up and see you know justice wants to
come up and see you sometimes so we'll
we'll make it happen
all right got an open invitation there
Thank You coach four more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]